[Music]
first question I think most of us are
take for granted you know that we
understand how the universe began with
the Big Bang or so but as they
understand it constructor theory is now
offering a new wave in thinking about
that as well you might be able to
explain a bit more about that and how
constricted theory offers an alternative
to the existing models well yes I mean
this is of course a program we have so
I'll explain the gist of it the idea
that this is something we would like to
do so the standard way of describing the
universe that we've had so far is to try
to guess a law that that explains what
trajectory the universe is on and that
means just like you would do with the
with a ball and you know when you kick
it and you would like to know where it
goes all the points in space-time that
he goes through from the start to the
end you'd like to do the same with the
universe and and we have some candidates
for that but there is of course a
problem in setting the initial
conditions and also in explaining why
some initial conditions as opposed to
others construct atheria is a completely
different approach to explaining physics
so instead of talking about those of
motion trajectories and things like that
the main statements of the theory are
about what translations are possible or
impossible on a particular subset of
systems of the universe and then from
those constraints for example an example
of those constraints could be the
conservation of energy which we already
know about
but constructor Theory adds additional
constraints from those constraints you
construct the dynamical laws that are
compatible with that and the initial
conditions and therefore those
constraints become the explanations for
those dynamical laws and initial
conditions so the logic is somehow
inverted and there is an idea that this
could be more fruitful in solving some
of these problems that currently we have
with the initial conditions of the
universe but of course as I said this is
is something we are trying to work out
and first we are planning to construct a
theory to a subsystem of the universe to
find predictions about certain other
problems the cosmological problem is is
a very interesting one by something that
is going to be worked out in the future
for doing the physics job you have to
solve problems that come up in your
understanding of physical reality the
way you see it around you and in a way
it's it's very simple the way you do
that is just you come up with
explanations that seem to make sense of
those problems and solve them so for
example when you know you you saw the
sky being full of stars and planets and
things like that and at some point we
were wondering why is it that they seem
to move and why is it that the Sun
seemed to move and why is it that this
doesn't fit with the idea that the earth
is at the center of the universe which
was what we thought initially and that
was a problem and and we found a way of
explaining the reality better in the way
that the problem this was resolved with
with Newton's laws and gravitation
etcetera etc so for that type of
activity you don't really need to think
that out there there is or there isn't
particular law you're just trying to
address a problem in your understanding
of course it might be more beautiful in
a way to think that there is reality out
there and it's actually in my view but
this way in a way it's an assumption
that I am making to make my worldview
more consistent the idea that actually
there are laws out there and I'm trying
to discover them and this is all
tentative we can never know that the law
that we have is the right one but what
we can say is whether it is or is not
problematic and if it is then we can try
to find one that isn't by solving
problems so I'm thinking the fundamental
thing that you have to assume is way
in a way is the idea that you want to
solve problems and then you have a way
of solving them by coming up with new
explanations and then if you like you
can say oh well actually these
explanations are trying to reach for
these actual laws that are out there I
like to think it like that but I don't
think is necessary well well there is
one important thing about science which
is that it has to be criticized about so
you know you come up with a new idea to
describe the universe and then you have
to give the means to the scientific
community to assess whether that idea
does or doesn't solve the problem that
you came up with that idea for and and
the way you the usual way in which
physics does that the creat is the way
we should criticize theories in physics
is to test their predictions so I would
say there's a requirement for
explanations in physics that they should
be testable because that's the way in
which you can find errors or mistakes
and make progress 10 - to me so it's not
quite just up to the physicists to
believe in what they're doing there is
this idea that whatever they come up
with to solve a particular problem
should be should be possible to be
assessed by this this testing business
in a way that that if it's wrong it can
be replaced otherwise we enter the
domain of these other theories which are
dogmatic theories where you know for
example religion is an example of that
where you have a set of truths which are
just there and they can be criticized
but that's not science so so if you want
to do physics ultimately you have to you
know you have to test your theories
against experiments and that's the way
you find errors in in in them what I
would say dogmatism is is perhaps
informs a view of describing reality
which is a little bit a bit limited
because as I said as soon as you stick
to a Dogma then you are not free of
making criticisms about it so if at some
point something arises around you which
doesn't quite fit the dogma
you're not allowed by the rules of
dogmatism to say well maybe I have to
change the dogmas and you know
incorporate a new statement to make
sense of what's going on so I think
dogmatism is just perhaps a bad way of
explaining reality and that science at
least is free of this idea that that
there can't be errors it's a very
liberatory type of view that you know
you're allowed to make mistakes and
actually making mistakes is good and
we're finally was saying at some point
that we should we should find out our
mistakes as fast as possible because
that's actually what you do when you do
physics you know you make an assumption
then you question it you try to probe it
with your own self see whether you can
find some contradiction
if not then you talk to your colleague
and then he's gonna say well actually I
don't think it works like that it'd be
different and so on and ultimately you
test against experiments and and the
fact that you are allowed to change your
mind is actually the most powerful thing
in science I I quite like this well
there are a number of things so I quite
like the interdisciplinary aspect so the
fact that all of these debates and talks
at cetera are not phrased in in in terms
of the actual topics that arise within
disciplines but they try to address big
problems like you know is their reality
or not etc and and these type of
problems are by nature they are
cross-discipline which is why the
fashion was so interesting this is
something we can't do in departments
because you know there's just physics
department as a mathematics department
as a philosophy department and we're
just divided by subject but actually
it's quite contrary to the spirit of
scientific investigation and more
broadly intellectual investigation
because we are solvers of problems and
problems are across discipline by their
own nature
so I guess epistemologically this
festival is actually quite right in the
way it's it's
constructive and that's the beauty of it
and of course also I quite like the
relaxed atmosphere the fact that
everyone is here to enjoy themselves
because I think that's ultimately what
we do when we do physics in my case or
we are up to our intellectual and that
was for the other people here we're
actually having fun so answering one of
these questions is fun and finding an
answer it's fun and this is an
underlying theme of this festival that's
what I like in it for more debates talks
and interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you